[ __ ]
[Music]
all right everybody you asked for it and
now you're going to get it here it is
the epilogue of saddest party on the
Citadel Baldwin Shepard is here to
finish his destiny oh I'm excited him
too for those curious we do have the
extended cuts do the extended cut we did
we you we started after but uh Cortez
did die yeah oh by the way Cortez is
dead and here we are sprinting at the
portal like a dingus but doesn't matter
baldwin Shepard can take anything he's
AI helmet off you he's got that helmet
on we've seen them take multiple rockets
to the chest and like not even flinch so
oh [ __ ] so we have some pretty low um
was a Galactic readiness or whatever
another fine
you
goodbye Liara and james well two more
cross them off the list we finally got
rid of it I think that look on his face
was like shocked that happened he's like
yeah justice I've been I've been trying
for so long
lots a lot lots of Makos are flipping
over here and this is when the
indoctrination starts right start that
it makes sense though
don't don't know why to them to always
helmet where's all of his armor huh a
doctrine ation that is always funny to
me is how his armor is now completely
different it's the original armor it's I
mean the only explanation is
indoctrination
is that that British guy in the trailer
you know doesn't we're in regular
traction all nice you kill them I take
credit for that of course Baldwin
Shepherds going to take credit for that
nice headshot
goodbye marauder shields there he is
that face
ready to save the galaxy
save does that mean the these dudes the
uh working for the Reapers the entire
time I mean they were but like I assume
their goal was just to keep the station
online but is a real goal to like a
harvest people funnel yeah I don't know
it's kinda gross Anderson
man the keepers are weird maybe I'm not
remembering this part but how does the
elusive man get here oh I don't remember
also where's everyone else in the
Citadel like are they all dead too yeah
I guess so I feel like we don't get the
points for that though since we didn't
do that now
oh he's indoctrinated everyone's
indoctrinated
I underestimated you
[Music]
mmm see those things he's indoctrinated
no and you can do this hold the whole
thing still not a believer not looking
so good yeah your skin is kind of gone
you have to imagine something's wrong
with you if that happens like maybe
you're not you're following the wrong
you're on the wrong team maybe totally
look at the power
well there's another one I guess we end
I guess Shepard does kind of kill
Anderson yeah and who we used an old
soldier stuck in his ways only able to
see the world down the barrel of a gun
sounds pretty good to me
yep you don't do everything I've
accomplished I won't let that everyone
knows the carnufex pistol is better than
what he just got yeah not worried now
you're the one faith and you will die
did you hit that urn I did okay so you
shot Anderson I guess that was weird
you
[Music]
man what I kind of disappointing ending
for a cool character I know right how
the elusive man was so much more
interesting than kind of the ended him
yeah
does this mean we don't get our epic
speech with Anderson at the end or like
really sad goodbye moment I I don't know
we'll find and Baldwin's ever Shepard
doesn't deserve this yeah a moment I
guess we never really established if he
hates uh if he hated Anderson or
anything like did he have anything
against Anderson did you want to kill
him too he just want to kill a squad
really yeah
and people who got in his way or people
who like look funny or people just
people yeah I guess yeah Anderson wants
to yeah he falls into that oh yeah so we
get this cutscene of it being heavily
damaged because we've done such a poor
job I've actually never gotten this
lending myself to be honest I don't
think I have either so that's the thing
if we do the destruction ending it'll
sure will wipe out like a ton of people
yeah we won't wipe out the whole galaxy
but we'll actually wipe out like a most
of them which ones destruction inning is
if we shoot the kid right now that's a
destruction any things that we shoot the
red the red beam okay okay
which is to destroy the Reapers ending
but depending how well it does it'll
like because the crucible is heavily
damaged it won't be able to detect
friend versus foe so it'll actually just
destroy a lot of humans as well hmm
so we'll just kind of wipe out most
people so how are we gonna end it though
are we going to shoot the kid oh yeah
we're going to go crack kid
Wow I guess we don't get our moment with
Anderson yeah I guess not
it's got a [ __ ] up especially cuz
there's a really good scene he's just
thinking about everyone he's killed up
until now is he feeling regret no
definitely not
regret that he couldn't kill more yeah
if anything he's still alive sure now
there he is the little [ __ ] The Crucible
changed me created new possibilities but
I can't make them happen if there is to
be a new solution you must act it is now
in your power to control us
so the aleutian man was right after all
yes but he could never have taken
control because we already controlled
him but I can you will die you will
control us but you will lose everything
you have
oh yeah losing [ __ ] it's war so I could
give up everything I have the path is
open there's only one way ahead wait and
you must now choose so we don't even get
the other we only had one option right
yeah we didn't even get the red one yeah
we didn't get the red I didn't realize I
thought just no matter what you get
those two are fought for alright let's
get this over with
let's end this do what you must oh I
will do what I must
all right shoot the little [ __ ] yeah
yeah all that work
he looks satisfied
[Music]
you
[Music]